empieza a llegar la ayuda a la comunidad
llanomami de Brasil después de que el
gobierno de Lula da Silva decretara el
pasado 20 de enero la emergencia de
salud pública en la región amazónica
algunas compañías aéreas comenzaron a
llegar al territorio para evacuar
enfermos muchos de ellos menores para
poder acceder a tratamientos médicos se
necesitan avionetas y helicópteros por
lo que 40 pistas de aterrizaje
permanecen activas
la tierra indígena tiene más de 30.000
personas y se necesita transporte aéreo
tanto para evacuar a los Indígenas
enfermos como para traer víveres
la salud de los Llanos mami la comunidad
indígena más grande de Brasil se ha
deteriorado en los últimos años debido a
la minería presente en tierras fértiles
que contamina ríos y otras fuentes de
agua como consecuencia enfermedades como
la malaria se han disparado en los
últimos dos años con más de 44.000 casos
según datos oficiales otras condiciones
infecciosas como gripe o anemias también
se pueden convertir en mortales por la
falta de
sabe que nosotros sabemos que en los
últimos años la situación ha empeorado
hasta llegar al punto donde estamos
ahora
además al menos 570 menores murieron
durante el mandato del ultraderechista
Yair bolsonaro que potenció las
actividades extractivistas y dejó de
lado a la comunidad empuje cuatro años
el pueblo llanomami desde hace cuatro
años solo estamos llorando la comunidad
de luto los niños enfermos el pasado
jueves 26 de enero la Corte Suprema
emitía un comunicado en el que ponía de
relieve la dejación de funciones del
expresidente un extremo que ahora Lula
da Silva quiere revertir